all right mimi
where'd you grow up where are you from
originally um um i was born in el
salvador i grew up on the east side
of l.a
yes and tell me about your family
growing up you had both your parents um
growing up i was with mom and stepdad
to about 10 and once i turned 13 i grew
up in the system from then your parents
lost you at 13
yeah my mom lost me at 13.
why was that
it was just um
abusive
relationship with me and my mom we never
got along was never on the same page i
started running away
uh
using drugs and all type of different
stuff because i didn't feel loved at
home
but
i mean so from 13 on
yeah from 13 on up in the streets and
stuff
is that when prostitution started for
you
no i would say prostitution started um
once i got into placement and i
turned 14. around 14. around 14 i
started prostituting and
at first it was more of
a shame thing i was just doing it to
survive
but then i actually started liking it
and
i just started shutting my body for me
um
having sex with different type of
guys and ages and all type of stuff
i got into
the first year of high school i got into
a relationship
uh within a relationship with my pimp uh
he introduced me to methamphetamine
started doing methamphetamine
and
just
started giving that guy all my money and
he used to beat me and stuff like that
but
i mean
that's the only way i know how to
survive out here so
that's all i do that's all i know did
you go to high school
you said what did you finish high school
i did i graduated high school 2018
so i can say i graduated high
that's
school
you remember your first time doing this
kind of work
oh
so i know it was at the age of 14
i want to say it was a
october
[Music]
i want to say it was october like
right um
right when i was i want to say i was in
like the seventh grade in middle school
i was very young when i started
who was the first guy that
who was your first client
my first guy i slept with was
i was
oh still baby i guess so the first guy
said
he was about 35
35 and um
i remember crying the first time i ever
did it i cried i cried and i cried
but after a while it's
you you just learn how to block your
mind you
feel me you just lay there and let them
do what they do
and try not to think about it
once i started doing methamphetamine i
would get
high
then
in the sky and
so i wouldn't feel nothing or you feel
me are drugs necessary to do this kind
of work
you have to be drunk or high i don't
have to but i've been doing it for so
long and i and
that's the only thing that how i know
how to work and how i'm able to do the
work so for i can't speak for other
girls but for me yeah i have to be high
to be
able to maintain myself
and are you making are you working with
a pimp today
no i don't have a paper right now are
you saving money
of course yeah i want to go to college
eventually and stuff like that change my
life around
but
no i don't have a pimp i don't
just still work in the streets
and
i have this online bank and
i just put up
whatever money i can because i still got
to make sure i eat i have somewhere to
lay my head at night
so
yeah
where do you do you have an apartment or
do you just go motel the motel no i live
in hotels right now yeah yeah girls do
huh that's what most of the girls do
yeah i stay in motels right now
do you have children
no no children
you've been in love before i've been
what have you been in life
in love yeah i fell in love twice
put it up twice but um it didn't work
out
so i just moved on yeah do you still
talk with your family
uh no i don't i have no type of
relationship with my family i have a
little sister that i love
but i'm not able to go around here
because of what i do
and my type of lifestyle how old are you
now i'm 21. 21.
what emotions does this kind of work
bring up for you
honestly for you learn
when you do this type of work
and you're in it for so long
and you're on drugs you don't have no
emotions i don't have no emotions i
can't tell you how i feel be right now
because honestly i don't feel it it
didn't it became my regular life it's
just something i'll wake up and do every
day
it's interesting
do you think you get desensitized to all
the dangers that are out there it's a
dangerous lifestyle
you know girls get raped and robbed and
yeah i've been i've been i've been
molested twice
and um
raped one time
recently so
um
i just recently when i got raped i just
laid there
and
i i don't know i try not to think about
it
as much
was there any sexual abuse in your
childhood
yeah uh
my
when i got molested twice by my
stepfather
how old were you i was um about 10 it
went until like 12.
do you feel like that kind of opened the
door for this kind of work
yeah i would say yeah it opened up your
world of experiences to sex work yeah
like yeah
does does this kind of work
build your self-esteem or does it knock
it down or does it do both
um it can do both eyes because the guys
are all driving around telling you how
beautiful you are
yeah but see um
i mean guys i'm you for me i do what i
do i'm a prostitute so of course
any guy is going to tell me what i want
to hear and tell me i'm beautiful and
all that stuff i
think the way i see it's like a job so
um
it's like my private life i keep with my
private life and my street life i keep
with my street life
so
i just
it in my private life
yeah i got selfish i got high
self-esteem but in my street life i
don't i go out there and i tell myself i
don't want to do this no more but
i have to do it until i'm able to get
back on my feet or
until i'm ready to change my lifestyle
around because right now i'm not ready
it's i've been in it too long
that it's kind of you know even got
regular this is regular for me every day
yeah do you think you're addicted to
this
this kind of work
um
it's a fast money and
yeah
yeah i don't like to be told what to do
i don't like rules so
yeah i think that's why i'm still in
this
job and this lifestyle
because i don't know
what is first to have a regular job or
be in a regular home i can't tell you
the last time i slept in a regular bed
there's times where i can't i don't
usually i don't feel like going out
there because i'm so tired i'm coming
down off the
and even i just don't go to work and i
gotta sleep out in the streets and stuff
you must get depressing no
yeah it does
yes
what was the best time of your life
what's your best memory
um
honestly i don't have one
right now i could i can't think
i want at the top of my
head i think
the most thing i'm grateful and best
thing that's ever happened is my little
sister
so yeah
do you think you've changed from doing
this kind of work
yeah it's made me grow up a lot faster
than
um
than you would have otherwise yeah i
didn't
get to have a regular normal teenage
life go out with my friends to the mall
eat some ice cream or any of that so
yeah most definitely it's
made me go
into the woman i am today yeah do you
think you see men differently because of
this
these experiences you're having
most definitely i still i mean i'm
i guess i'm such a nice person i still
believe in good men is out there
but
men are men
do you ever stand back and just look at
how crazy this this
style of this lifestyle is yeah i do
it's dangerous and it's yes
yeah dangerous you must have had dreams
of doing something as a young girl
yeah
i wanted to i want to study for
emergency medical technicians eventually
you can tell you that yeah everybody
tell me that i just
i gotta get off this lifestyle first
make a hard decision one day yeah one
yeah one day but i do plan to i plan
before my 30th birthday i do plan to be
somewhere else in my life
so right now i'm just trying to
continue this lifestyle save up and
give you all my feed little by little
have you heard bad things happen to you
out there
you mentioned you were raped and stuff
like that
rob sometimes and things like that
um
no i have not been robbed yet
do you carry protection like gun or
i carry a pocket knife and pepper spray
when i'm out there have you ever had to
use them
yeah i had to pepper spray a couple guys
before
i had
you been arrested
not for prostitution no
is it interesting that they caught you
you were figaro street
um
no i think it's just regular uh what
streets do you work
i work um fig and century
it's interesting how the cops will
sometimes just cruise by and they know
the girls are what they're doing but
they're not arrested yeah they're not
arrested i mean i know i know yeah i
know recently
yeah i know recently they trying to
start
arresting us for being out there and
stuff like that because it's minors out
there
but
i mean what can you guys really do
do you get to some of your tricks asking
you to do risky things
no
um i only mess with um
i don't mess with color i never had a
black trick before yeah a lot of girls
tell me tell me that yeah i don't have
like tricks for a reason because
because i didn't because they're
dangerous like i know what uh um the
things i can get away with a black trick
or what a white trick
like i can't get away with the same
thing i can get away with a white trick
with a black trick you know you might
just meet the wrong trick is you for me
that might be the last day
so i prefer not to uh
do any type of business with black males
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
um
never give up
no matter what never give up uh
it's never too late uh
it's never too late to change
yeah i hope you do
thank you
all right mimi thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you i wish you
the best of luck getting
into a new career one day okay thank you
you